Ukraine politicians play a vital role in
serving their people and telling the
world the reality of the war
so today I am very honored to welcome
you Mr Speaker
the last time we met was virtually a
year ago
when we convened an extraordinary
meeting of the G7 speakers to discuss
the situation in Ukraine as you warned
that sanctions imposed by the West on
Russia needed to go further
some deeply honored and so pleased that
we can finally meet in person
as I tell you at that special Gathering
we in the UK are in awe at the way
Ukraine continues to stand up against
your Russian aggressions
how your conduct your Parliament the way
that you continue is incredible despite
the challenging situation you face the
very fact that you continue to meet and
legislate is a powerful and defiant
symbol of strength
I am I am told your president when he
addresses in February we will continue
to support you our Parliament is your
Parliament the form is once again
another opportunity for us to show our
solidarity with you
so sir and your delegation the most
welcome here today and please we'll be
honored if you would say a few words I
know
that you have come here as a friend
seeking more support we are a friend
that will listen we are a friend that
will support and continue support I have
to leave now it's not meaning to be
discourteous but as you know all
challenges take different ways
unfortunately Dr Benja I'm sad to say is
retiring going to his own college at
Cambridge this morning we penciled in
and we got the interviews
for the successor to Dr Benja it
to fill those great shoes but what I
would say is please let me apologize
that I do have to leave but I will
remind you now I am here for you and
please enjoy this visit but let's get
the backing that you need for the future
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
thank you
the right honorable Speaker of the House
honorable members of the House of lures
and the House of Commons dear friends
first of all allow me to thank you right
honorable Cyril in the oil for your
initiative and the opportunity to
address the members of the UK in this
unique circle and to address members of
parliament of the UK
I'm extremely happy to be here to gather
with the Russian delegation
the representatives represent all of the
parts and fractions of the parliament
and this means that the parliament is
the United and is one in this war I'd
like to thank all of you members of
Ireland that you are together with the
Ukrainian Parliament we are doing
everything to reach our joint Victory
together
dear colleagues it is very important for
me that today the consolidation between
our parliaments between the Ukraine and
Parliament and Parliament that is one of
the oldest in the world the Parliament
that gifted the world many parliamentary
Traditions today we are
joinedly together I'm grateful thank you
for this next I'd like to thank every
British person everyone who opened the
door of your houses for over 160
Ukrainian refugees
they found here The Refuge and they can
hide from this terrible word
especially big Thanks goes
to those British families of
the UK MPS because you are the leaders
in these directions you demonstrate high
level of support to Ukrainian people
also
uh honorable colleagues I would like to
emphasize and I would like to thank for
all of the effort that the UK already
put with regards to Ukrainian people you
were the first
who supported Ukraine
and who gave Ukraine thanks you started
tank Coalition for Ukraine it was the
world tank Coalition you were the first
to start training our Ukrainian Soldier
you
gave them your knowledge your experience
your skills and you see how today
Ukrainian Soldiers with decency use it
and this dignity on the better field
your decision on Challenger 2 opened the
way to other countries giving us stocks
you are making huge contribution to the
resisting the enemies on the land in the
air and on the sea
which is why I think today
is the time
for Britain to become a leader
to also open so-called
flight uh Squadron to open the the to
Ukraine the door to use aircrafts and
also long range Rockets which is why I
will be truly grateful if Parliament
also will stimulate the decision or on
this matter for Ukraine and in support
of Ukraine the thing is the weapon that
you give and the the defense means
already said thousands of lives of
civilians and I would like to thank you
for this today the whole world admires
the braver of Ukraine and I would like
to thank you for The Bravery of the UK
people of British people because you
give such a high level of support to
Ukraine
today is the time
to do more radical actions you know it's
not only about
technolization of Ukrainian troops
only High Technologies
complicated weapon
can have us to reach the pivotal point
on the battlefield which is why I ask
you to support in your Parliament the
decision in support of Ukraine
we also need to go towards
peace
and Ukraine today suggested to the whole
world
clear formula peace formula the author
is president of Ukraine volodimir
zielinski's clear 10 points they are
clear easy to understand comprehensive
it's not only easy to suggest to the
world they will bring Fair peace Fair
peace on the terms of the country that
is a victim of this war never confuse
who is the aggressor and who is
the aggrieved party the victim I know
that Britain supported this formula on
the general assembly of un
141 countries supported many points on
this formula
I also would like to address today
and speak about some of the direction of
this formula for example one of the
strategy to fight the aggression of
Russia is to take away from the
aggressor their ability to conduct War
which is why sanctions is not a silver
bullet
and neither is political nor legal
pressure against the aggressor have our
assumptions along the international
isolation of Ukraine decrease their
military potential on daily basis as
well as linear opportunities in
searching for allies and we are
conscious that sanctions also affect the
livelihood of the citizens of Partners
we do not wish our partners to pay for
the consequences of Russian aggression
we always speak
that the only guilty party in this
aggression the only guilty party and the
consequences of aggression is Russian
Federation is Putin is Russian people
it is them
who have to receive the check and pay
for this horrible aggression this
tragedy and War
which is why I have a few historical
questions
shoot the representatives of moscow's
regime be loved to decide what measures
to use in support and restoration of
International Peace and security
obviously not
should Russian Urban Russian athletes be
allowed to take part in the Olympics
obviously in what
is why the reservation of Russia from
all of the Civilized worlds should be
also our Joint Task
and we speak and we will keep talking
about this on every International
platform
which is why today I would like to ask
you the UK
do you allow us to express this on the
G7 parliamentary Summits and dg20 uh
plot for and at any other platform that
needs to hear Ukraine voice and for this
opportunity me as the head of the
Ukrainian Parliament and we the MPS
today face to face would like to
communicate this matter to you
honorable and peace
in addition we would like to continue
the UK Parliament to see as a
participant of the Parliamentary
dimension of the international Crimea
platform as you know last year we have
established this platform this year this
Summit will be taking part in Czech
Republic and I am inviting and I have
already invited the right honorable
speaker to join this platform and I
would like to invite him to visit
Ukraine for us it will be a great honor
to receive this
right honorable speaker of your
Parliament
uh their quotes honorable colleagues I
would like to focus your attention on
another Metro
this this will be the anniversary of the
liberation of Ukrainian territories the
regions of key featuring became the
first regions cleared of occupants
The Liberation became a happy event for
us however it has also been a territory
discovery
at that exact time we saw the real
consequences and understood the aims of
the aggressor because the next day after
Liberation European butcher has told
president of Ukraine myself and MPS
we visited those places and they've seen
what is the so-called Russian uh peace
or Russian World the only aim is to
destroy Ukraine
they are destroying us only because we
are ukrainians and
this idea alone
historically is very typical to Russians
90 years ago the same was done by Stalin
regime with regards to Ukraine 90 years
ago Ukraine survived the most horrible
genocide
holodomor this is how we call it which
is why I would like to ask you honorable
members of parliament it would be big
value that today you take the decision
to recognize kolodo more as a genocide
against
Ukrainian people in 1932-33 this
historically is connected this is
Heritage of Ukraine to everything that
is Ukraine they showed it demonstrated
that 90 years ago they are demonstrating
it today honorable colleagues the only
difference is that the tool at the time
was farming and now is most destruction
weapon and crimes war crimes and war
crimes against humanity
the victory on the battlefield is very
important but it's not sufficient for us
is very important is
to reach the victory during a legal
debates we want to use all of the legal
mechanisms so that Russia
is defeated legally so that Russia is
recognized as a terrorist country
country aggressor and the most important
is the country that will behold
accountable for all of the wars that
they commit crimes that they commit in
Ukraine which is why
we upload to the decision to issue a
rest order these regards to uh fusion
and his complexes and they have to be
hold accountable in all of the national
and international jurisdictions for us
it is very important that today
uh United Kingdom not only supported
this initiative but also appealed to
other nations to join the work and
organize a special tribunal this
tribunal is supposed to investigate
crimes of aggressor
please agree with me that the
prosecution of the guilty parties
wouldn't be real and the Victory
wouldn't be real if they are not
prosecuted which is why I would like to
say honorable colleagues Ukraine will
win
the Democratic world will win
fairness will be restored the world has
changed its unrecognizable noise and we
all understand that future Security will
depend on our ability
to have to establish new guarantees and
to protect our citizens and there is no
doubt that Ukraine will play very
important and sometimes a leading role
in many mattress
soon we'll be summoned NATO and they
will decide a lot of on a lot of matters
this can be very good start it can be
defining on Ukraine and the whole North
Atlantic community
today Ukraine de facto is part of NATO
Ukraine today's complete the functions
that are based on NATO principles
because now Ukraine defends countries of
Russia of NATO paying with the lives of
our sons and our daughters they give
life and health to protect you which is
why our membership if not will not only
benefit the Ukrainian people it will
also rein feel strengthen the alliance
which is why I appeal to you to become
the part of the consensus and support
our application and to start immediately
work on Ukraine joining NATO because
we only are strong when we are together
I believe in Ukraine I believe that we
will overcome all of the consequences
and I believe that all of this work
Starts Now if this is why I am grateful
to United Kingdom
and the good outcomes of the conference
on the restoration of Ukraine that will
be held in London in June of this year
we have the paths the way
in front of us and we will go together
and we will act with dignity together
thank you for your attention glory to
Ukraine
foreign
s and it's a privilege for me to compare
the Q a section now of the discussion
first of all they want to thank speakers
definitely for a fascinating overview of
these situation in Ukraine you painted a
picture with absolute Clarity of the
terms of Engagement the terms of War and
the necessary steps to produce peace
it was really interesting for us to hear
the historic context The Wider historic
overview that you presented and I
thought it was especially interesting
that as well as talking about the
necessary military solution to this
conflict who talked in terms of the rule
of law and the inevitable as you saw it
legal consequences something you as a
legal expert I think well understand and
then finally you set it to need the
wider International context the
possibility of NATO membership and an
eventual return to a new world order so
I want to thank you for that in the room
we have colleagues from all parts of the
House services both House services we've
got members of the House of Commons
members of the House of Lords we have
staff of the House of Commons staff of
the House of laws we have MP staff and
we have journalist colleagues so in this
Sea of Faces I'm afraid I only know a
relatively small proportion and I
probably can't see them anyway so if you
could kindly raise your hands and then I
think a microphone will find its way
towards you
could I ask please that you ask your
questions fairly slowly because we have
interpretation and that helps The
Interpreter handle the question and
deliver it smoothly so who wants to go
first I see a hand at the back of the
room so the microphone's going to wing
its way down there
if you could introduce yourself as well
please when you ask your question that
would be very helpful for our guest
thank you I'm baroness Finley of land of
I'm an independent cross bench peer in
the House of Lords
my question relates not so much to the
high level political but to the
Grassroots and I wonder what you feel
should be done over the propaganda
war that is also going on and how the
West could increase awareness of the war
crimes that you've spoken about and of
the difficulties because in social media
across Western Nations there is a great
deal of Grassroots political power
thank you
foreign
thank you for your question
my honest opinion is that this war
demonstrated that propaganda is a weapon
it is type of a weapon very similar to
the weapon that used on the battlefield
my personal view is the direct contacts
and the opportunities to deliver
information
directly from the members of parliament
to the members of parliament is the best
which is why I'm here today I have the
delegation from the parliament of
Ukraine they will work with you together
today I know that there are some
contacts that have already been
established and you will have
uh the opportunity to hear it from the
horse's mouth what is happening in
Ukraine we all have to understand that
we have to do everything that Russian
propaganda that is very generous and
they broadcast their views to the whole
worlds we need to develop the antidote
and communicate our views to the whole
world because this whole Russian World
brought by Russia must be stopped and
the war must be stopped with the victory
of Ukraine and after then we have to
have a clear idea of This Global
Security in the global world and we have
to protect the
civilized world and the new rules of the
International
Communication and cooperation needs to
be established and I'm grateful to the
UK Parliament it is very important
questions and we have to find joint
answers thank you
foreign
thank you my name is Jeremy Purvis I'm
the liberal Democrat Foreign Affairs
spokesman in the House of Lords I've had
the pleasure of visiting the vikov
Narada on a number of occasions prior to
the full Russian engagement
Invasion and I admire you greatly for
your ability to carry on as a
legislature in Dreadful circumstances
since I've in a recent debate that we
had in the House of Lords I suggested
that it could be appropriate that the
UK's highest civilian order the George
medal could be awarded should be awarded
to the book of Narada for the
inspiration that you have given for
parliaments around the world as
institutions
my question relates to practical support
that you may need or desire from the UK
and others
if their if peace is not secured early
and as a parliament you need to carry on
in your proceedings and secondly if
there is a situation soon
how the parliament will need support
to move from emergency legislation in a
state of emergency
towards reforming back to full civil
Authority this will I can imagine this
would be a very difficult task
required for staff and members and can
the UK Parliament or other institutions
support that and finally I've called on
the UK to ensure that there is a
parliament strand in the Reconstruction
conference so that supporting Parliament
and MPS is also part of the discussions
in addition to economic support and
strategic and Military and security
support thank you
is a thank you for your questions very
important question because it is to do
with the quality of our Parliament I
would like to say that before this
meeting we have signed the memorandum of
cooperation between the parliaments it
will be the next level uh this was
signed by the heads of our parliaments
and their Clear Directions that we would
like to work together on secondly I'd
like to emphasize that from the 24th of
February and until today
the parliament of Ukraine Works 24 7. we
work in the same building we didn't
leave our building we didn't run away we
are in the same place where the
parliament of Ukraine should be
last year the number of the legislations
that we have taken and approved in the
parliament is higher than the year
before this is because we needed a lot
of new legislations in support of our
war situation this was very important we
also worked towards the reforms the
reform of court
anti-corruption reform uh European uh
Union integration we work together and
we
work jointly
uh yeah I always say that there are some
groups that are envying us how we came
together although the political parties
and group and we are working together
because we agreed in the beginning of
the war we won't have any different
groups and a different fractions we will
have one United group because that's how
we can withstand the enemies with
regards to the economy
in this direction it will be air very
important the conference in June this
year will be held in London it will be
represented with the parliament
aspect as well and I'm very hopeful that
between you and IV as members of
parliament will find the way of the
economical development for Russia first
of all confiscation a rest of the assets
of Russian federations this is very
important matter because now we need a
universal for you formula that will
change the world
so that the country's sovereignty of
Russia as a country aggression is
recognized and it will allow us to
freeze to freeze and arrest assets of
Russia as a state of
individuals from Russia there are many
directions many events we need to move
forwards we need to keep going and I'd
like to thank members of the parliament
of the UK Parliament again and this is
my task to thank you and to keep working
together
this morning a service agreement with my
counterpart in the Ukrainian Parliament
for cooperation between the house
services in the Commons and in Ukraine
with a view to facilitating an exchange
program and further development work so
we're really looking forward to working
on that who has the next question I
think the lady here
if I may if the speaker lets me
Alexandria
[Music]
and about the Union in the Parliament
that is there now and probably Ukraine
is a unique country that doesn't only
have trains running on time in the
wartime but also passing the reform
bills I know when we talk about the
Reconstruction when we talk about the
conferences I know I come from the
anti-corruption NGO before and for the
parliament I know this is one of the key
questions that is being brought up so we
are probably a unique country that is
has the judicial reform running the way
the not only the Civil Society and
international Partners wanted but the
Ukrainian Society we have now new judges
being elected the high judicial
commission is totally new people that
came out of the system and we have we
see that there will be the rule of law
actually in times of War installed in
our country established in our country
I'm so sorry to say that and I just
wanted to add briefly on the propaganda
and I know it's we're going to run into
this issue more and more I'm chairing
the commission on all the military
assistance coming to Ukraine it was
opposition that was picked to run the
commission because it's important that
we are not being accused of actually
doing what the maturity wants to do and
we know there is a lot of propaganda
right now about Ukraine smuggling
weapons doing stuff like that none of
the international reports ran into that
this was true
we had been working with a lot of
governments with with a lot of the
police outside every time one of the
reports comes out in one of the media's
worldwide in France in Bulgaria in
Finland
there had been statements not only from
our police but from the police from
those countries this has been a fake
report
so we know we are going to run into this
issue and uh we are not stupid to shoot
ourselves in our leg with stuff like
that but we know Russians will be trying
to take opportunity to do that so please
the best thing to do is to contact your
counterparts to do the investigation
like the CNN did who was trying to buy
javelins and laws and stingers and ended
up that it was fake it's impossible to
buy that so we would be really grateful
that if you ever have questions we are
there for you and we are ready to report
to bring all the information up and we
had given all the access to your
military on the transparency monitoring
and lunch in the NATO systems of
logistics of reporting that to make sure
our International Partners who are
supporting us now are satisfied what was
what they get in their reports thank you
thank you
municipate Andrew
I was just going to ask about the
process of European integration about I
know Ukraine is aiming to join the
European Union and that will involve a
lot of you know involved putting
European laws from European Union into
Ukrainian law and I was asked wondering
what the preparations have been made for
that and how Ukraine will manage
Ukrainian Parliament will manage the
process of implementing European
legislation into into Ukrainian laws who
continue to integrate with European
Union in the future
Jackie
Jack will show us thank you very much
for your question
the matter of Euro integration is about
increasing the standards in Ukraine and
I would like to highlight the role of
the parliament in this matter
last year's summer time we received the
candidacy status and also Ukraine
received seven recommendations that
Ukraine was supposed to
fulfill so that Ukraine can become a
member of a Euro on the 13th of December
last year Ukrainian Parliament
has made the last legislation has
supported last legislation that was
necessary to achieve all of the seven
recommendations with regards to the
evaluation of the people of Ukraine of
the parliaments of the of President as a
head of the country
the positive feedback we are happy to
continue
comprehensive negotiations with European
Union they are hoping that European
Union will value the dynamic that
Ukraine demonstrated and before the end
of this year
there will be a decision made with
regards to the membership of Ukraine in
European Union
also in at the end of last year as a
head of the parliament as the speaker of
the parliament I have sent to all of the
leader or leaders of the EU countries
with the recommendation that the
parliament of Ukraine made so we are
very confident in these matters and we
also expect on a fair evaluation from
European Union
we heard overnight that Ukrainian troops
have trained finished their training on
British Challenger two tanks how
important could they be on the
battlefield and does Ukraine need more
British tanks going forward
with regards to the training mattress
during
my address I have thanked
the UK for the training delivered to our
servicemen our servicemen are trained in
line with the native standard and that
includes Challenger 2. we are ready for
more intense training of Ukrainian
servicemen because we expect that this
will mean that Ukraine will be able to
receive a new
Weaponry system they are ready to send
our Pilots to be trained to use a
fighter jets because this would mean
that Ukraine might open the door of
opportunities to receive the fighter
jets we keep saying please give us your
experience after we will receive the
wings and we'll be flying in the air we
will bring Victory to Ukraine and we
hope that
you and I we will receive joint victory
for the world and for Ukraine
thank you
my name is Suraj cement I am a
researcher for a member of parliament in
the House of Commons
my question is the UK and us have done
so much in terms of providing material
assistance to Ukraine and to her people
um but it's very clear that Russia is
also targeting the cultural and
spiritual inheritance of Ukraine
um what more is it that the UK can do to
support freedom of worship and belief
because it's becoming quite clear that
the Russian Federation is deliberately
targeting mosques churches synagogues
and freedom of worship more widely in
Ukraine
foreign
I'd like to start with the topic that I
am the person who was educated during
Soviet Union Union I had access to
Russian Classics Pushkin this year's
kiss and so on today we have to be frank
and honest with the whole world the
Russia bombards us today not with the
not throwing the books on our heads not
Pushkin investors they throw rockets on
our heads
people who came to Ukraine they are
Barbarian people who never read neither
Pushkin nor dostoyensky nor do they've
seen a lot our task today to communicate
this to the whole world so that the
world knows about it so that all of
those topics that Russian propaganda
communicates to the world about their
huge cultural heritage it's just cheap
propaganda to give today Russian people
have nothing in common with this
culture or inheritance big
inheritance today what they bring is not
the civilization of the 20th century
it's the civilizations of the 19th 18th
and sometimes 12th century it's not the
civilization we want to go into we want
to be with the Civilized world in the
future which is why we do all of this
work and in Ukraine we've already we
already understood what it's about and
we want the whole world to understand
this
good morning
um and thank you very much for your very
powerful words Matt Weston Member of
Parliament for Warwick and lemington
um just beyond the military support uh
which of course we are very pleased to
give you
um I'm just thinking about what else the
UK can help provide particularly when it
comes to energy resilience to support
you
um through not just this year but maybe
for longer what uh
funds or Technologies or equipment we
can provide to help diversify and make
you energy resilient and secondly with
water support and and supplies too and
then a further point which might seem
unusual but I'm just looking across at
fellow MPS in the Ukrainian Parliament
and thinking is there anything that us
as individual members of parliament can
do to help them as individuals it must
be an incredibly tough time for them we
can't imagine but is there something we
can do to them as individuals
foreign
I visit a lot of parliaments and often
the most frequent question is what can
we do for Ukraine this is very important
and Ukraine well use such approach and
those questions which is why when we
speak what can we do in other sectors
not only in the military sector the
priority is the restoration of Ukraine
the restoration should be a success
story for the whole civilized World
which is why energetic security and
safety of Ukraine technological
restoration is important Ukraine is
destroying uh the environment it's
horrible
the matter of his regards to the
National critical sites are very
important the restoration renewal of the
economy important financial and bank
system of Ukraine is strong we are
holding together but it's only thanks to
the international partners because you
are supporting Ukraine because Ukraine
spends a lot of budget on the defense
with regards to other mattress I say
that they are very concretely
highlighted in the peace formula the
formula piece of President zelenski
because what we need not only to achieve
Victory we want not only to survive we
need to win this is very important that
we have good joint work and
collaboration between our parliaments
and between our
members of parliament so I emphasize
that all of the fractions and groups are
active and I'm sure that you will find
the bridges and will build personal
relations with our members of the
parliaments and they will in detail
explain you what is it that we need what
we need for the Victory and what we need
in support of the regions of Ukraine
because it's very important to rebuild
Ukraine and to demonstrate that there is
a light and the light
and we will win against the dark Forces
thank you
my hand a little bit thank you so much
for your question and um
there are so many things that need to be
done we talk about the bomb shelters for
kids because our children cannot go to
school there is no bomb shoulder for
that and unfortunately it's billions
that it has to be invested to build that
and we have to learn how to live in this
reality for a very long time because
unfortunately our neighbor is not going
to go away
in terms of the support for the energy
sector
I just I just want you to understand me
properly but we had been asking for
generators and telling that the
challenge would start long before it
happened and when we keep asking for the
air for the Jets that the speaker was
mentioning we understand that this is
critical for us so we don't have to
invest more in energy later because the
carpet bombings the Russians had been
talking a lot about that and we know
this is going to be crucial for us with
our Energy System and with our Railway
system we need a lot right now to invest
in our health care
because a lot of the uh hospitals were
ruined and this is critical for us and
the rehabilitation and I know there is a
very big uh knowledge there's a lot of
knowledge in UK for that and we really
hope that this something that you could
bring and help us with our soldiers and
not only soldiers let's be honest
probably the majority of people in
Ukraine right now have PTSD we just
don't realize that we're just leaving
this stage of work not understanding
when it's going to end so we would we
would be very grateful if we could
continue working with you through
different and I know we have a really
good friendship group that is working
with you but there is definitely a
certain in every sphere there is need
and there is understanding what needs to
be done and we would be grateful for any
kind of support thanks
questions
Jonathan chinockley MP for Huntington uh
thank you Mr Speaker we met last in your
Capital uh where you uh hosted us and
it's very nice to see you here today in
Parliament
um I'm sure everyone in this room would
be very pleased to have heard about the
uh International
icc's decision to prosecute uh Vladimir
Putin I know that at the same time
concurrently there is a proposal led by
Ukraine for a special tribunal to be set
up to prosecute
senior Russians for the crime of
aggression a
charge which isn't possible through the
ICC and I'd be grateful if you could
just advise us what the latest is in
terms of building up the International
Community
required to put together such a Tribunal
but Daniel
the same
the matter of specialized tribunal is a
matter of justice and fair enough
because
only International
Court
we need to have a special Tribunal
and we think that it needs to be created
in the aspect of looking into the crime
of this aggression and in addition to
the arrest order preaching has to be
convicted by the ICC and by the special
tribunal there is one word to this
fairness fairness needs to be restored
this fairness should demonstrate for you
future to everybody that no one in the
world has the right to do what they are
pleased in the 21st of sanctuary to
retailer the borders of democratic
country and the responsibility has to be
as soon as possible with regards to the
help very important that the discussion
that is conducted today with regards to
the creation of tribunal is supported
supported in every country this
specialized tribunal would should be
created stated there are mechanism I
hope that we will come to the Joint
decision with regards to the format of
such specialized tribunal and the work
starts as soon as possible our Ministry
of Foreign Affairs is doing this work we
are joining the discussions all the time
they expect the decisions of other
countries and we are grateful to Britain
and Britain's support this idea idea of
the creation of this special tribunal
and I emphasize one more time it is very
important not only for Ukraine but for
the whole world
I'd like to thank Mr Speaker for kindly
offering his rooms for us today I'd like
to thank our translation team who've
done a fantastic job and all the team
behind the scenes particularly the
speaker staff who've set everything up
today at very short notice but above all
I'd like us all pleased to thank speaker
subject for a fascinating overview of
events in Ukraine thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
well I will try
thank you
[Music]